oh no
what did you bri this is not at all what
i thought we were gonna be looking at
like the movement and how they're doing
everything is just at another level
this is kind of like the pitch piece
yeah but then got turned into basically
a bigger pitch piece i guess that was
going to be my question i thought this
was anime is this not
big thanks to vessi shoes for sponsoring
today's episode at the end of this video
i'll tell you how you can get 25
off your own pair of vessy shoes
hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of animators react we are here
joined by alex who is a professional
animator that's worked on a bunch of
films that you've probably heard of
right now i'm working on the recently
announced bad guys over at dreamworks as
well as cool new things over at double
plus animation so we're gonna show him a
bunch of cool stuff and show him some
anime and see what he thinks about that
maybe you can break down what makes it
so special you've seen the thumbnail you
know we're gonna be talking about this
episode let's get to it
i'm scared dad what if i can't do this
follow me
okay so this is a show called invincible
on prime video i have no idea what this
is so invincible it's a comic that's
been going on a long time it's created
by robert kirkman who also created a
little indie project called the walking
dead i've never heard of it yeah it's
the zombies i don't know a little while
ago it got greenlit as both an animation
series as well as a feature film live
action it's also for a more adult
oriented demographic it's a bit of a new
thing we haven't seen a lot of adult
animation in the us that's why anime is
so cool is like anime is not the genre
it's just like how they do it
[Music]
man flash is coming out of nowhere a lot
[Music]
see those action lines
that's not where i expected the scene to
go
oh no
oh my god
when she coughs out the blood after her
head is turned around or just like
this is not at all what i thought we
were gonna be looking at the difference
is you're used to seeing cartoons that
look similar to this not being anywhere
close to this violent yeah i mean in a
nutshell this is what invincible is
there is definitely things that are
being used in a very anime adjacent way
with close-ups small reactions but the
choreography in this is really like
adjacent for me to a studio mirror style
way of thinking where everything is
grounded character-based movement this
is definitely like taking the things you
like about a superhero show and turning
them on their head which is exactly what
the comic book did and i think it's
successful where it's not successful is
when you see invincible flying around
sometimes he definitely feels like a cut
out just kind of moving around and
that's 100 coming from budget in time i
do feel like the flash for in particular
doing this fight scene is a little
lackluster yeah like just the pure red
stripe it's just a single static pose it
feels like they had to bust this shot
out like a day it's like the poses
aren't really all that dynamic there's
really no communication of energy you
know like they're not even moving there
there's no like wiggle of the fabric i
know the skin type costumes yeah you
know something that you see a lot of
anime when things go into slow motion
the clothes still move at regular scenes
yeah people could be going
but like all the time
it's funny those reaction shots after
that he kills the flash they become less
and less animated as the reactions go on
yeah like like really animated yeah
animated just the camera zoom just
nothing
but you know you see limitations of like
when he's squeezing his face it's really
just like his head and his eye kind of
like overlapping there's not new
elements there's no angle change any
kind of detail like that and that's
where for me seeing the limitations
takes me out of it like i want to see a
reaction not just a still frame if this
is your big scene just go all out and
let me live in it to be fair there's an
argument to be made there of the less is
better so that the explosion counts you
still ramp up the anticipation more too
you know yeah
versus yeah
yeah
i think there's a lot to be left wanted
from this but as an experience and
everything leading up to this i do
believe they're treating the animation
and their limitations in the correct way
and guided by the right reasons i do
think they did an awesome job at
bringing the comic to life from story to
visual
my grandmother used to tell me stories
about the old days a hundred years
passed and my brother and i discovered
the new avatar
an airbender named aang
i always knew you returned oh yeah this
is that show that was made by m night
shyamalan
yep this is the one are you ready i'm
ready
this show has like a special place in my
heart because it kind of brought anime
back in my life a little bit and now
this could be considered not anime but
anime inspired i guess that was going to
be my question i thought this was anime
is this not it depends who you ask anime
is technically like animation done in
japan and usually it's energy action
oriented both from a character
perspective and a visual perspective i
mean this is a us-driven show but the
animation was done in korea
at the time when this came out there was
nothing else like it it really pushed
everything for cartoons it pushed
storytelling in a whole new direction it
pushed the idea of like serialized major
animation especially on a channel like
nickelodeon way further than i had ever
seen before and then visually it just
was like
on a whole nother level
i feel like they're really nailing fire
animation here because fire is something
that is kind of interesting to do
because it glows it emits light the way
this is animated is so fantastic because
even as he uses fire to fly as he
changes his direction he's kind of
turning off that power and then
redirecting you see it in like baymax or
iron man or these higher detailed
characters
a couple things are really standing out
to me is that they have a tendency to
hold takes for a long time and it's not
overly cut they're not really relying on
a bunch of like close-up shaky camera to
hide animation yeah they're not shying
away they're really just like living in
it i mean it's just at a higher quality
a higher drawing count and pencil
mileage the use of effects the detail in
the effects i mean like wren said the
fire is amazing the how they're treating
wind water everything is so cool and
unique and thought out and so integrated
into the characters it really pushed on
every level there was a moment a little
earlier when they were flying through
all the pillars there and it almost
looked like it was a cg scene but i
don't think it was that's definitely cg
was it i mean cg in the central are
probably 2d cutouts in a 3d space yes i
think what they're using is like a
parallax layering where they have
multiple versions of this pillar and
they're just like stacking them and
integrating them and then doing a camera
something that i think people just take
for granted when watching this or don't
really think about is
air you know he's the air bender he's
bending air so you have to somehow
demonstrate and animate air but it's
something that's invisible and so you
have a lot of these creative liberties
where it's like oh we'll just make the
air kind of like transparent water in a
way we'll have white action lines for
the movement and like we've all learned
to speak that in terms of cinematic
languages oh that's air we all accept
that it's air even though visually air
looks nothing like yeah it doesn't exist
so this shot here we're seeing an
orbiting camera going around it but it's
animated how are they separating the
foreground elements from the background
my guess is that they're basically
animating the two characters and that is
just a giant long painting that they're
just scrolling sideways the other option
would be to do almost the same exact
painting but project it on a sphere and
then track it okay both of them are
viable and and useful for different
reasons the way they did effects and the
way they did martial arts is so cool in
the show i'm noticing so much of the
actual choreography is so smoothly done
are they using like reference are they
actually bringing in martial artists to
record them doing something to be like
oh yes i see how you're moving there and
then 100 so they had like a lot of time
beforehand to figure out these different
styles that represented different
elements so like tai chi being water
because it's smoother and flows from
your
air is more smooth and monk like and
more about the poses it's putting
everything together it's not straight
fighting it's not straight anime where
it's all about nothing but the motion or
the feeling so there's much more of a
global reach in all these styles right
okay so i think that's
really heightened the level of animation
from traditional 2d tv stuff all the way
to a spider-verse or a mitchells
anything else really starting to push
the limits of artistry and animation
okay i want to get more into anime leave
a comment down below with what you think
is the best anime and i'll check it out
yeah would more comments on this video
than any other video
avatar aang accomplished many remarkable
things in his life
but sadly his time in this world came to
an end
and like the cycle of the seasons
the cycle of the avatar began anew
i'm the avatar you gotta deal with it so
a lot of people think that jm animation
or the same studio that did avatar did
cora so what happened is from my
understanding jay mong who was one of
the head people at jm animation he
started his own studio called studio mir
and they are responsible for korra but
the core of it is it's a different
studio with a lot of the same members
like the same dna the same dna
like the movement and how they're doing
everything is just at another level like
the amount of martial arts reference
being used in a clever way mixed with
the bending in core they start
experimenting of like if you have fire
or can produce heat what could you do to
metal and so you're getting to
experience fight sequences that are
using elements in a new and exciting way
martial arts in a new and exciting way
and their environments in a new exciting
way and then visually just the frame
count like i talked about before i mean
we're talking jumping from three
thousand four thousand drawings in an
episode this is close to fifteen to
twenty thousand an episode i'm
definitely noticing the detail and the
layers going on here there's a lot going
on it's just crazy you're also going to
see a lot more use of cg in a way that
you probably won't notice the cg
vehicles and things like that it's being
used and rendered in a way that you
don't care about but the effects are
still heavily 2d they're just being
smarter about their production but
maintaining the quality and the
importance of the story
[Music]
so alex you often talk about how there's
a studio like an american studio working
on this but then you also mentioned how
there's a korean studio that does the
animation so what's going on there is
the korean studio doing the drawing or
is american studio doing the drawing
how's this working the answer is yes
this is a show that's green lit by an
american company it's like hiring an
animation studio it's just they happen
to be in korea a lot of the
pre-production or front end of stuff
usually happens wherever it's being
greenlit and then you decide where that
shifts and how much that shifts so it
could shift entirely to studio mirror to
do awesome boards because they have the
artists and they have a mindset and they
know the world at this point but you
could still have people on the
nickelodeon side stepping in or doing
boards or doing draw overs or doing
things to maintain the quality and guide
the larger team are most of the
in-betweening studios in korea or
i would say it's a mix as of right now
it seems like korea has a major
expansion into the realm of anime
inspired work if you want a show that
looks like this there's only so many
studios that you have access to the
anime studios are more closed off in
creating their own content whereas korea
seems more open to working on partnered
animations with american creators and
studios and because of their history
with avatar growing in decorah and
beyond have learned how good of an
experience that is and how you push each
other
avatar and cora introduced this kind of
new stylization which is much more
difficult and detailed than something
like adventure time or steven universe
but it's a lot less detailed than
something like out of high school where
you're gonna see like the threads on
their shirt you know
and that's why you're not gonna find a
lot of studios like studio mirror and
other studios that are kind of pushing
these boundaries okay you keep talking
about studio mirror but you've said that
you've done some work with them before
yeah so a few years back i created this
project called koji for the most part i
was a co-writer and producer and
co-director on this so okay so this is
basically your brainchild here okay
let's take a look i'm interested
[Music]
for me koji was a passion project i
envisioned a certain way and i was like
i can just chip away at this for the
rest of my life and be okay with it you
know my thoughts were if i want to make
this into a series i need to know how
much money it would cost so i reached
out to them and i just kind of wanted to
know what they would cost to maybe make
a trailer or a pilot we ended up making
this little trailer of koji from the
original idea
so for a piece like this are people
still drawing this on
like cells like is this still hand drawn
or is this all being drawn in a computer
so for this it's kind of like cora where
there are elements clearly cg i think
they're probably utilizing digital
painting as you can see in the
background but the animation is
hand-drawn so pencil and paper i can't
help but notice like how clean
the drawings are to the point where it's
like it doesn't feel like you could get
to be that clean if you actually drew it
by hand you know you get the pen
bleeding a little bit into the fibers of
the paper or yeah pencil issues or you
know paint lines how are they actually
getting such clean drawings so with most
productions i would say that the cleanup
and the color is primarily digital if
not completely there's the rough pass
the tie-down pass which just starts
being on model the cleanup pass so it's
just like one clean line i imagine the
cleanup pass is digital here because
then the color is digital as well and
you need to create those interesting so
that you can fill the color so you can
use technology to your advantage would
it be possible to see the original
trailer that you made for
[Music]
this this is kind of like the pitch
piece yeah but then it got turned into
basically a bigger pitch piece yeah
exactly i really was using a piece for a
long time the guardians of the galaxy
commercial for disney xd the way it used
camera moves and the way it flowed but i
was after that kind of style i just
lucked out into stumbling into that
artist his name is maxine delande he
just like nailed this
it's got a pixar look to it
i like how when she shoots the arrow we
actually see the painted action lines
yeah like the action lines are there but
literally as brush strokes yeah
background so we wanted to make sure the
style was true to itself throughout if
that's the brush stroke if that's the
pencil being used we want it to be used
throughout so this all feels integrated
and where i'm taking in this piece in
particular like from pixar aesthetics
and appeal just because it's been
ingrained in me throughout what i've
been exposed to the most and bringing
elements that i like from anime without
losing like the story elements of a
pixar movie or character elements from
these high level like dreamworks in
disney all i have is nice things to say
about studio mir and and our work
together on this i grew so much
artistically from this experience but
their team really just took it to
another
over
level
yo what up son i'm here to tell you guys
about today's epic sponsor vessi shoes
and uh i've got my shoes right here you
may have noticed almost everyone in the
studio wears vessi shoes why is that
well i'm gonna have the shoes do the
talking okay are you ready
[Music]
vasey shoes are 100 waterproof meaning
you can wear them in rain snow sleet mud
and any other form of water that might
appear on the surface of the earth wow i
didn't know that thanks for telling me
guys we're also made of an incredibly
useful dimetex material meaning that we
will keep you cool in the summer and
warm in the winter that's right
we have an oh all-weather grip meaning
that you can wear us on a hike or while
you're traveling or in an urban
environment street out with friends
wearing with grandma wearing with mom
and dad wearing with your kids
these guys are pretty good i gotta say i
mean i'm convinced so far what other
what else do you guys have to say about
yourselves well if you didn't notice
jake we're highly stretchy
[Music]
that's right we're highly stretchy
wow
vesey is
constantly thinking about the
environmental impact that their shoes
head might have meaning that they have
an incredibly efficient production
process well hey thanks guys for keeping
me so informed on why these shoes are so
incredible no problem jake if you're
interested head on over to
veseyfootwear.com
corner crew and you'll get 25 off your
first order
really 25 off my first order that's
right 25
link in the description below
link in the description below
thanks guys
thank you so much for watching this was
a really fun one this is very
eye-opening
thanks for coming on alex this has been
a blast i hope we have you back at some
point soon maybe we'll actually finally
take a look at love death and robots
people have been asking for it for two
years now and redline i know redline's
amazing i watch it so good next episode
if you want to see more of alex's stuff
go over to instagram he's snomation or
you can check out his bigger projects at
doubleplus productions we'll see you
guys next time
stay tuned let's go get some smash in
smashing we'll see you next time
especially if you've subscribed